I was very that was very nice thank you
very much I've never been whistle
introduced all right flight please does
that look correct alrighty good hi
everyone my name is Giani net I'm a
JavaScript developer from Berlin and I'd
like to thank the J's conf Iceland
organizes that they invited me to close
their very fine conference it is an
honor the title of this talk is the
state of the JavaScript community when
you look at the topics that were
presented just here at this event you
will quickly see that there's not one
JavaScript conference but many at sorry
community not one JavaScript community
but many JavaScript communities we might
write code in the same language but our
interests are web internet of things
virtual reality and plenty of subgroups
as well front and back and robots
bicycles and and add our community is
really a set of communities and that's a
good thing the more communities we have
in JavaScript the more interesting
people we have joining and the these new
people are finding new problems to solve
in JavaScript and then they will find
even more solutions to these problems in
JavaScript and then other JavaScript
communities can take these solutions and
apply them to their field for example
jQuery a phenomenally successful project
has a hazard its core a feature making
the dome of vile beast of browser
programming more accessible to a lot
more people to the point where people
were more jquery developers than
JavaScript developers it was that
successful for still is when Rick
Waldron wanted to get people to use
JavaScript to control robots he created
the library or the library johnny-five
and aside from a great name he stole the
idea from jQuery that making the complex
world of hardware more accessible to
more people will lead to success and it
worked this cross-pollination of ideas
happens all the time and it's fantastic
I'm very happy the JavaScript community
is so diverse in topics as far as
overused aphorisms go software is eating
the world is as good as any now in
JavaScript that's already know in
software javascript is every
it's used for everything and most
developers that do something else also
do at least a little bit of JavaScript
by any measure javascript is the biggest
most successful programming language of
our time or even all time so when
software's eating the world and
javascript is eating software so
javascript is eating the world that's
not good thesis here a better world we
as a set of JavaScript communities have
a significant impact on the world we
shape its future this is why now more
than ever it is important to look at our
culture because our culture informs who
we are and where we are going and who
are we taking who we are taking along
for the ride today the JavaScript
community and the culture is me straight
white male upper middle class Westerner
with all the privilege in the world and
that's great for me and everyone who
looks like me but most of the people on
this planet do not look like me and if
we were building a future for everyone
we need to have representatives of
everyone participate in our making of
that future they need to be part of our
culture or design and business decisions
building software is an act of
representation just one chilling example
when Facebook change this default
privacy setting for group memberships to
public a queer person from an area that
is traditionally not as open-minded got
the membership in a queer choir revealed
revealed to their parents putting that
person at significant personal risk if
Facebook's product managers and
designers or developers will include
more queer people this product design
decision would have known would have not
gone through most software's design and
build without any understanding of a
circumstance of the majority of the
people that end up using that software
and the results are increasingly
terrible I just need to point at
Twitter's rampant abuse problem in the
cultural inability to deal with this
it's not that they can't solve this they
don't want to at most of us are kind of
okay with that in his book creativity
ink at Catmull the founder of pixar
reveals one of the cornerstones of
pixels continued success success heights
failure and success makes
in short true long-term sustainability
comes from introspecting ones failures
and staying vigilant about one's works
downsides especially especially in the
face of massive success there is no
argument to be lost that javascript is
successful so let's introspect our
culture and let's be vigilant about our
work discussing this whole topic
comprehensively would probably take a
couple of days so I'm just picking a few
things so we can get this discussion
started one of the cornerstones of our
community is open source most of the
software we use dailies open source or
build an open source and most of our
tooling as developers is also open
source and as someone who has deep roots
in an open open source this is fantastic
this is the kind of world I want to live
in what do I in the past few months
three major JavaScript projects
announced that the one person that was
left maintaining them is leaving and the
project would be abandoned more or less
what happens is this somebody published
something useful in github and NPM and a
ton of people start using and relying on
it eventually the support burden and
user questions issue reports pull
requests and so on overwhelmed the
individual and they get overworked or
worse burned out we had a show of hands
about burnout in the opening talk by
miles yesterday and a no fair number of
you have experience with this my hand
certainly went up and I hope we can
avoid for the rest of you to ever have
to deal with this by the way three
projects were grunt power and uglify
that millions of people depended on it
is obvious that our culture doesn't
include a way to make open source
projects sustainable and it puts our
infrastructure at risk and it more
importantly it puts the people in our
community at risk there are many many
things that we can do to improve this
there are many many problems that we
need to be improving but I was recently
on a podcast called request for commits
that's a new thing that came out because
I had blocked about this topic last
winter and I don't have time to go into
all the things to cover all the things
but if you're interested in that
specific part like please come up to me
later and we can talk about this if
there's one thing I want to pick one
thing that we can be doing to improve
this and like if we can get the scouring
this will be really good
when reporting issues to package
maintain errs be nice I understand that
it is very very frustrating to spend
hours or days to find out that the small
mistake in a dependent they're like very
deep down in their dependency tree
causes you grief but letting that
frustration out on the package
maintainer has terrible consequences one
your incentive of course is to get the
issue fixed the number one thing you can
do to make sure somebody is absolutely
not inclined to work for you for free is
yelling at them and calling them names I
know most of you are clever enough to
understand that and understand this and
mature enough to not behave that way the
second terrible consequence is that
you're very likely not the only one
doing this not you specifically you know
what I mean and even if one abusive
issue might not cause any problems for a
maintainer which is already unlikely
getting one every week or one every day
elevates the maintain is personal
frustration to a constant stream of
so-called microaggressions and these
drain their emotional resources most
people leave open source because of
because of the abuse of their emotional
labor women and under sorry women and
other underrepresented groups ee or
triply sir because they don't only have
to deal with this but have the technical
abilities questions non-stop as well
like I said before there are a lot of
things that we can be doing but everyone
here should start not should start not
being an [ __ ] on github and also help
out to create a culture of no tolerance
for [ __ ] in JavaScript when we do
that we will be significantly better
better position to make our community
more sustainable as miles pointed out in
a in his opening talk for us humans this
is the natural thing to do and as an
added benefit our culture will be
perceived as more friendly and welcoming
so we have bigger chance of attracting
more new people and keeping them in the
community to benefit from their
experience that Jenna just showed us how
do you drink
another angle of sustainability is the
ability to pay people for their work
especially those who are not naturally
privileged enough to work in open source
otherwise and of course some open source
projects are funded by corporations but
the majority is not and at one point or
another this is going to be a problem
many here will be familiar with the
heartbleed vulnerability that was
discovered in openssl a while back and
that revealed two things first everyone
and their dog was relying on open SSL
for mission-critical encryption work
second the code was basically maintained
but by one person in their spare time
what could possibly go wrong this got
addressed fairly quickly but most open
source project are not as prolific while
still being the foundation of a lot of
other software open and closed and they
receive zero funding we have no culture
of making sure open source projects are
financially sustainable and we even have
people argue that money ruins open
source but that that these people could
be not more misguided I want to give
special thanks to Nadia Iqbal who's been
doing fantastic research on this topic
and it's now working at github to help
address this issue more broadly there
are links to her work at the end of my
slides can have enough drink tension of
the pause the technology industry is not
very diverse an open source is even
worse took me ages to come up with the
rhyme for this only twenty to
twenty-five percent of people in tech
are women and one to five maybe ten
percent of people in open source are
women trending downwards and we don't
even if numbers for the Democratic
demographics of other underrepresented
people in tech but the numbers will be a
lot worse we have a lot of work to do
it's a quick interlude on the words of
inclusion and diversity just to clear up
any misconceptions inclusion is everyone
and their dog are happy to be part of
your community and they can safely
engage like any other member and have
fun doing so and get support when they
needed diversity is when people get a
lot with a lot of background different
backgrounds and experience are part of
your community and these experience
inform your community's activities and
make them better stronger more resilient
and ultimately more successful as a
result basically repeating with Jenna
just
on our slide thank you very much further
for the pre-work there and if you want
to learn more about this again at the
end of the slides with a bunch of videos
by someone called Lina Reinhard who's
given a bunch of fantastic talks about
this that will really inform you about
this now inclusivity must come before
diversity and diversity is a consequence
of inclusivity if you're trying to
increase diversity without making things
inclusive you not only set yourself up
for failure but new but for new
individuals will have they will have
horrible consequences at experiences so
don't do that so this is all a bit
sobering so let's look at some of the
good things like this kitten I have this
in my browser or command 35 being a bad
day or a bad moment of a really others
helps this is good let's do this for a
bit outside like miles to do like a
psychedelic version of this place
something I absolutely love about
javascript is the sense of collaboration
to move our collective understandings of
solutions forward I love the pace at
which this happens I like our community
gets a lot of attention by big
commercial players without any one of
them dominating and I like how
successful the whole bundle is we even
do get we do sorry we even get
competition right imagine ember didn't
have to compete with react they would
have never rewritten the rendering
engine to be faster than react and then
react would never have let that slide
and improve them they're designed to be
amber again and then ember one-up them
again and so on and like the
proliferation of useful ideas mentioned
before this also happens all the time
and we're all better off because of this
it clear downside of this and after
think I have to credit fellow speaker
marie cocco soccer for this idea is that
a lot of this happens in pacific time
maybe in the overlap of us eastern
pacific time asia and the EU play clear
second fiddle in this and while the pace
is thrilling sometimes these thing can't
seem to wait for a planet rotation so
everybody gets to say this limits our
view for solving issues the best way and
we can do a lot better we're doing
really well in edgy
I think aside from all the great online
resources everywhere there are events
like notes school and note together and
a lot of others that bring more people
into this community with the focus on
learning and collaboration and with the
strong culture of trying to include and
make safes make a safe space for
everyone I love the nature of
experimentation in our community for
example the continuum between fully
serviced I'd rendered sites and fully
front and rendered apps and everything
in between and the continuously shifting
trade-offs and the resulting technical
solutions they all set up set us up for
a better for a better future one of
these experiments is very close to my
heart it's a small modules one I fully
believe in the small modules philosophy
and semantic versioning in NPM and all
of that heck I even helped run
greenkeeper to make with the goal of
making all this best better for the
whole NPM community so we don't have the
full picture yet but the sub stachy and
extreme of everyone combining their
small modules from first principle has
its limits as has the not invented here
Laden no dependencies are right now on
one orlith way of programming and we're
continuously learning new things and
invent new tools that radically change
the way our habits in one way or another
and fascinating to follow a really like
what we're doing sometimes takes a
little longer if I figure something out
but eventually we'll get there I think
it's really cool while there are many
communities in JavaScript the biggest
one is clearly the web and that's my
origin story too I'm a child of the web
I believe it is one of the wonders of
the world and worth preserving one of
the most fascinating things about the
web is that it was designed with a focus
on the individual user one key component
the browser is an agent for the user it
works on behalf of the user given that
the web is so commercially significant
this design is a revolutionary to this
day when the web was invented
everybody's data lived on their
computers and browsers made sure that
websites couldn't steal that data now
everybody's data lives in the cloud and
browsers are ill-equipped to deal with
this new reality of so called corporate
surveillance this is something native
mobile especially us has an edge on the
weapon there's a few more things where
the web slagging be
however a lot of a lot of that is
getting addressed and I'm very happy to
see the progressive web app movement
embracing the mobile web as a first
class citizen I'm particularly excited
about this because about three years ago
in preparation for a workshop that we
did in most fast London I can't coined
the term of line first which is now an
industry standard Tom and the thinking
behind progressive web apps fully
embraced the offline first ideas it's
really cool around that time three years
ago we had built the first version of
hoodie and offline first backend for
your front-end web apps and while
service workers and the like weren't
around yet we were and still are
building fully offline capable web
applications assets data everything and
with hoodie we made things we made that
accessible to a lot more people taking a
book out of the jQuery in Johnny Five
playbook where we grew a little bit
early though because now I believe all
that fun stuff with having data offline
comes after you deserve Chris um but now
that we had three times to like mature
system at three years to mature system I
think now is the time for every one of
you to first learn service work and then
get into hoodie so that's really cool um
what I like most about progressive web
apps though is that they are designed
around a culture of empathy I'm else by
empathizing with users around the world
that may not have a gigabit fiber on
their phone for twenty-four seven we are
now building new web standards that will
inform our development culture to build
on the web with more people in mind this
is a very important shift in our culture
and couldn't be more happy about it
could be more happy to see it standards
my notes say waitful laughter so i'm
waiting for spaces thanks again to
Marika for bringing this up the old
saying goes standards are great there's
so many to choose from standardization
is what makes JavaScript the language
strong no single vendor can dictate what
the language is going to be and it's
very very powerful the same is true for
the surrounding technologies on the web
but standards processes are also not
very transparent first they are hidden
behind a bunch of acronyms that help
nobody really understand what is going
on w3c whatwg ECMA and it's just as
inaccessible as these acronyms are just
as inaccessible as these acronyms are so
the organization's behind them as well
as the processes you can contribute to
the HTML standard on github today did
you know that probably not do you feel
empowered to do so right now I don't
know about you but definitely not me so
you know how to get a seat on the tc39
the acronym committee that's inside the
ECMA acronym that defines the java /
standard i bet not and by the way i know
it's akma however can you guess how
diverse and inclusive these standards
groups are probably not very some of
them are realizing this and trying to
change it some don't and specifically
note core the team that is responsible
for building the runtime that runs all
our JavaScript's is openly reluctant to
become more inclusive despite numerous
people sending spending significant
amount of time trying to address the
issue because we have no culture of
demanding the diversity in our
leadership group and node core is a
leadership group node core gets away
with this we need to do better a lot of
technology happens in and around San
Francisco the melting pot nurse and the
abundance of capital allows the most
outlandish ideas
things to be tried out on the off chance
that they are useful later because
things are moving fast in technology
people are moving fast and technology
from a European perspective the US
employment laws facilitate this and
changing jobs every 6 to 12 months as
normal a two-year tenure the startup is
rare if not frowned upon as a result
things are really built with longevity
in mind when Twitter open source
bootstrap and it got really popular I
feared that as soon as the developers of
the sorry the Twitter employees leave
the project would be toast luckily that
has not happened because the bootstrap
developers left Twitter to go indie and
focus on bootstrap but that's not the
common story so as a result the rest of
the world has to deal with the
half-baked and short-sighted swath of
projects coming out of Silicon Valley
because our culture dictates that no
true software can develop anywhere else
and don't get me started on a region
that has witnessed a 40 year stretch of
hyper growth and that has produced more
millionaires and billionaires that
anyone cares to count and still has one
of the most rampant cases of
homelessness anywhere on this planet and
can't be bothered to do anything about
it other than creating a second layer of
reality for just tech workers what is
the point of innovation if you're not
building a better society most software
is designed and built without any
understanding of the circumstances of
the majority of the people that end up
using that software and the results are
increasingly terrible
miles brought up a lie ship in his
opening talk and as a whole we're liking
a culture of a laceup we are not very
good at this and i know i've personally
failed at this and probably continue to
do so i know what instance of known her
ass ax in our community not being called
out for their behavior despite enough
people knowing about it i've personally
got back got a hint of what was going on
a while back but i neglected to follow
up that was a mistake on my part because
i kept hearing in confidence that the
harasser has been making their rounds
through the community this particular
instance is now improving but all of
this happens behind the scenes because
we have no culture that knows how to
deal with this and there are so many
more cases that are not transparent to
this community or if they are they are
tolerated the sad thing is it probably
happened in this event as well it's just
the odds it's not likely that this
hasn't happened here so um I'm not here
to tell you what to think is right or
wrong I just want you to think for
yourself about our culture and what it
enables and if you are okay with that
are you okay with the fact that most
salaries in our industry come from
intrusive advertising that's beyond
creepy and as something sometimes
life-threatening consequences for
individuals or give governments and
cover the corporation's increasing
amount of power about our lives are you
okay with that we're actively excluding
the majority of humanity from
decision-making in technology and
especially JavaScript I okay with the
fact that our industry is built on
systemic oppression of anyone who's not
a white man are you okay with the fact
that rampant misogyny and abuse goes
relatively unchecked in our industry and
Jake Applebaum is just the proverbial
tip of the iceberg I okay with the fact
that women get systematically paid less
than men for the same job are you okay
with the fact that women of color get
paid even less for the same job are you
okay with the fact that people with an
african-american sounding name or fifty
percent less likely to get a job
interview I okay with the fact that most
startups founded and funded and thus
controlled by a demographic that just
does not have the purpose sorry just
does not have the perspective to wield
that power responsibly and who build
solutions for people like themselves
rather than the 99 percent rest of the
world I okay with the fact that we are
building our industry
on the foundation of volunteer and
emotional labor and burnout most of
these problems and are just problems in
the JavaScript community further
problems of the tech industry or society
at large so why should we care to fix
them number one because it affects us we
have leadership teams that are not
equipped to make white reaching
decisions and we and our project or
words off offer it our first motivation
could be that we make our own lives
better number to keeping our own hose
clean before asking others to keep
theirs it's kind of only logical three
it makes us more sustainable and said
sets us up for long-term success these
are fine reasons but more importantly
our culture increasingly defines the
world if we get it right it will spread
like our culture's already spreading I
believe it is imperative to leave the
world behind better than we found it and
as such it is our moral duty to make
sure our culture's one the generations
to come can build upon and be proud of I
don't want to be remembered to be the
generation that is missing out on
affecting much needed change as being
complacent in the face of overwhelming
evidence that despite our successes we
have a lot of work ahead of us I want
the closing speaker of JS conf Iceland
2066 remembers and say that generation
they really pulled their weight and set
us up for long-term success with a solid
foundation to build a community on and
to build software for everyone on this
planet with everyone on this planet that
is why I care and I hope that is why you
care to thank you very much